Okay, I'm gonna mostly skip over the first part of this,
cause it just cracks me up how, like,
a lot of men think that we dead
seriously believe that they're.
They're all suddenly women sports advocates.
There's nothing to do with the fact
that they view this as an opportunity
to villainize trans people.
So setting that part aside,
the second silly question.
Are you okay with Hennepin dictating the whole state's outcome?
Am I okay with the areas where all the people are, um,
having a disproportionate impact on the election?
Because people vote, land doesn't vote.
It's like, you know,
in the office, that time when Stanley's like,
I'm okay with the logic of it.
That's me. Yeah,
I'm completely fine with the logic of that.